starting off this hour Scot in Dayton
Ohio
hi Scott how are you hey Dave doing well
on you better than I deserve sir how can
I help
yes sir I'm trying to do my next move
here trying to figure out what my next
move is will be and my wife just started
out doing baby steps and just started
the budget this month good oh why my
wife was doing the budget before and we
just got no ground so I kind of stepped
in and said you know let's do this
together and make a plan of action and
try to dig ourselves out of this debt
and then find a place to live and you
know we're on baby step along still I'm
going to get about $500 saved I'm our
income is about $6,500 this month Wow
that's good yes sir went from we've been
married 15 months now and we were laid
off during our honeymoon so we've been
struggling in climbing since then and
Lords definitely blessed us okay
but we're saying in her parents basement
and raw baby step 1 and her sanity is
about gone and we need to try to figure
out next plan of action here we're about
thirty four thousand dollars in debt
total mostly mylan debt so you have
$6,500 coming in per month yes sir a
total bill who roughly give or take
about $1,500 so that does Lee was quite
a bit of wiggling but yeah I mean you
can go get an apartment and put up a
deposit right well that's the thing else
on the screen on the phone as I have
extenuating circumstance I know you talk
with other people we're kind of normal
people that don't have a weird
backgrounds well I'm a convicted sex
offender and I'm not able to just pick
up and say hey I want to rent this place
people are saying you know no to me all
the time so I bet um so um how long ago
I mean you have so you have a felony
conviction
and how long ago was that did you do
time yes sir I did eight years or seven
years and about four months and uh
followed by six years of probation
afterwards and yes I started doing za
long ago did you get out
Oh nein nein okay all right well I think
ha I won't be college I went to college
got my degree in civil engineering and
was not able to use my degree so okay
well I mean there's going to be you have
certain restrictions on where you can
actually live relative to a school or
that kind of a thing I assume right um
yes yes you know yes okay and and then I
assume that uh well or some kind of a
restriction I don't know what it is but
I mean I just assumed that I guess I
went too far but anyway I don't know
exactly what you did only get into that
the I'm just trying to help you from
where you are so what am I suppose you
need to identify that where you can
legally live number one and not be in
violation of something that the court
has told you okay
and in terms of once you've done that
then you've got to find just an
individual probably an individual
landlord that would consider your story
and that is is that since oh nine the
this in eight years prior that this is a
past history it's way back it's not
something that was six weeks ago you
know and so um you know then then if
someone's looking at this through a
corporate lens or through a narrow lens
they're not going to rent to you you're
right you've run into that but if you
find Joe and Joe and Susy that owned a
rental house and you could sit down with
them and go look you know 14 15 22 years
ago whatever the deal was you know and
then I served eight and then I'm out and
I'm been on my probation and you know
and we're making a living and we're good
people now that's in my past though and
I want to disclose that and I want to
see if you would give me a chance and
you know you find an individual person
that just looks at you as a person then
instead of as a as a checkmark on a box
in an application right and in those of
you can tell your true story and it's a
story of redemption and that you are
starting your life afresh then yeah
somebody will give you a shot but can
you just walk up to any old place and
rent no I agree with you you're going to
run into probably some pretty serious
knows and you probably already have
haven't you oh yes absolutely
but yeah you got to go shopping and you
got the money is the good news yeah well
you know saving that money when you we
were we were thinking that the next step
was just because we were having so many
problems system say for a down payment
on the home no I think you think you
rent okay you just got to find a place
and so you need to save you know several
thousand dollars this month and take a
month and go shopping for rentals
aggressively until you find something
that will give you a shot and then the
good news is you're going to be able
clean this up and work the normal baby
steps once you get you a place to live
that's not you're in your
mother-in-law's basement that's driving
you crazy
so I don't know yeah you know because
you're making good money between the two
of you yes sir and so yeah that's that's
good I think that's my plan I'm gonna
yes you've got some barriers but the
good news is you've got a pretty dadgum
good income to attack this with you're
going to be debt-free and you know like
a year and then you're going to save
your you know save your emergency fund
then you're going to save your down
payment and buy a house and you're gonna
be in good shape it's exactly what I
would do but I think you've got a hurdle
there but I don't think it's
insurmountable and as a landlord would
we rent to you possibly I mean I'm not
not going to rent to you based on the
information I know today but I'm not
gonna tell you no based on what I know
today and so if you sat down with my
son-in-law Winston who runs our rental
property and you told him the story and
he came to me and goes hey this is a
long time this guy's passed we're gonna
give this guy shot I'd be okay with that
if he if he checked you out and heard
your whole story and knew what was going
on and you know we're gonna give a guy
shot that's that's starting over it's 15
years later you know kind of a thing and
so
you know but but again we want to know
the that the story is still all positive
and if you've got that to tell that's a
good story
it's a redemption story used it's a
start over and story we live in a
culture full of people that start over
we're all people that start over so
people like to give somebody a shot if
there's a reason to give them a shot and
then there's others that are just
judgmental and then there's others that
are corporate America and they can't
make a decision that doesn't fit any
kind of checkbox on form and that's what
you run into so amen thanks for the call
I hope this works out for you I hope you
get your get you a place to live and
then get out of debt and save up your
emergency fund and save up your down
payment then you're able to move into a
house and do it do it the right way
good question and thank you for calling
in open phones this hours we talk about
your life and your money you'll get that
kind of call on the typical financial
show you know what not the typical
financial show this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you